the actual loss was 2500 plus whatever
uh plus the course that i spent on let
me be real with you okay
the man's instagram account says risky
ricky
some would say there were red flags
welcome to the internet detective 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla i hope you guys are doing
well
hey guys luck i'm just doing it for fun
this is for you guys
and yes it's true i mean literally guys
look at the name
they're telling you it's a gamble
they're saying hey even this one is
pretty dicey okay
it's not even it's not like steady gains
bernie madoff
it's like hey this is this is risky
if you stumbled across this page ah
you're in trouble just fair warning
pretty soon it's gonna be like instagram
account 4x scammer
trade at your own risk like in the bio
and it's like want to copy my exact
trades
he's a forex investor but he he didn't
even spell investor
right well i mean he spot it with like
the the dollar sign
this is not what rich people do you guys
he says my only instagram account he
also says he's an
educator and then he says copy my exact
trades
how much education do you need for that
to copy for your exact trades
right and then of course the instagram
account is your classic
i guess a golden lamborghini guys this
is not what rich people do
oh he's imitating the wolf of wall
street because all these guys worship
jordan belfort they're like oh you went
to prison
for fraud oh that's what i want to be
when i grow up let's imitate the movie
baby
i had someone reach out to me saying he
lost money with this guy we're gonna get
into the interview
with that guy in a second but before we
do let me just say
this is not what a trader does it's not
what a a real trader's instagram looks
like i'm sorry to say
in fact it's not with anyone who's rich
and kind of has money
looks like i decided to look up a few
rich people like legitimately wealthy
people
that a lot of these guys they like
worship i decided to look up their
instagrams right
first of all a lot of them don't have
instagram accounts that's first lesson
uh but second of all it's just like
run-of-the-mill stuff here's george
soros guys yeah old
george right where's the lambo i don't
see it someone tell george that he's
gotta look
rich he was gonna be rich right here's
zuckerberg
up where's the lambo where's the goal oh
it's just your family lame
still same thing it's like nothing right
but when you go to people like risky
ricky see he's got it figured out
got the cash sitting on the table this
is how poor people think rich people
behave
what trader at the end of their long day
has posted a picture like this that's
not trying to get a bunch of broke
kids to go invest in their signal group
or let me guess
you got a training course oh boy can't
wait for that to come out
but i love it's just kind of become
really transparent right i mean it's
like it's not even like they're not even
trying to hide it anymore
paid with tyler is another instagram
account where it's like oh we're not
even
trying to make this look legit i help
people make ten thousand dollars weekly
trading forex
right sure you do tyler yep just just
you know
rich guy things am i right guys so
anyway i thought i'd yeah
just introduce you to this victim of one
of these forex guys talk to him for a
bit
but don't do this please hey risky ricky
it's not worth it
don't do it why are we even sometimes
you guys have these people i'm like
and they're telling you like they're
trying to tell you that they're a scam
all right without further ado let's hear
from one of these guys who got scanned
by this
uh how much was it that you lost
uh the actual loss was 2500
plus whatever uh plus the course that i
spent on
now let me be honest with you rick uh
i'm about to call you ricky
ryan ryan let me be real with you okay
the man's instagram account says risky
ricky
and he spells investor with a dollar
sign
some would say there were red flags how
how did you get involved i'm just
kidding but how'd you get involved
and um you know tell me what got you
sucked into the whole thing
uh it was the cars honestly and like
when i first
wanted to get into trading uh
particularly forex
i kind of got lost in the sauce right so
i was bouncing around
and i saw i saw the money i saw the cars
i was like
this is dope this looks like it's
working so
let me see why they do it yep let me let
me see if this is legit
and sure enough um i got sucked in that
was probably
um with them for about maybe like two or
three months
and then it just snowballed into
sure enough um it turned out to a scam
for me and then i just saw a bunch of
red flags with his
with his courses and his uh i forget
what's what what he calls
yeah i know he's got i'm looking at his
instagram he says market
mastery academy yeah and he's got the uh
copy the exact traits
that are making me thousands per day so
he does a signals group did you get a
part of that
i did piece of that action how'd it go
you making money
i did not uh the risk to award is crap
so you would get stuff with you know if
you if you know about forex and those
who are listening
you'll get like 100 pip stop loss take
profit
100 pips for a stop loss is massive
and your your second take profit i think
it's only maybe like 1.2
or 1.5 your risk to reward so it's it's
trash
and it's going to take forever to get
there and no it's not worth it at all
well what'd you learn in his academy his
golden circle
it's mainly just what his
his course is like reversal patterns and
before i took the course i went to his
live event was actually i'm in las vegas
and this event was here in las vegas
so i went to that and apart from the
material it was just very poorly handled
i actually have
you know joking around some videos where
we showed up one morning
on time and the whole place was trash
because
everyone got drunk the night before ah i
mean it's risky
it's risky ricky though i can't get i
can't get over that name
why did he name himself that yeah
that doesn't scream um qualified
trustworthy
i don't know i kind of like that he's
sort of embracing his own
thing but obviously i don't like that
people are you know losing money
and when i first got into the golden
circle
you know he would and the golden circle
it wasn't necessarily it was
one for the um the signals and then one
for the actual um the golden circle is
you know a huge group that i hate that
he charges for but you know we got it
for
being there at the event and
um he was like one day he was like
hey i'm gonna pick one random person uh
to do
a strategy session with right like a
like a call
and you know he picked me and it
pretty much turned into a sales pitch
for a mentorship
well wait what do you mean what do you
mean he said i'll pick one of these
lucky guys don't you think he probably
just did it to everybody
maybe i don't know but he yeah i mean 50
minutes later
yeah if it's a giant pitch of course
it's gonna be like hey i'm gonna choose
one of you lucky guys
for sure now this was probably about two
years ago
so i was even younger at number then
[Music]
how old were you at that time uh 23.
yeah and um what do you do for work
uh at that time i was uh working for
insurance
okay and just looking for a way out yeah
yeah that's the thing that's what people
don't get is that that's mostly who
falls for these things it's people who
kind of work in grinds who want to get
out of sort of the
what they feel like is an inescapable
rat race someone comes and promises them
the dream and it's like
you want to seize that you're not some
and you know you're not an investment
banker making 300k a year
yeah it's your average kid that's tired
of working he wants the money wants to
wants to get rich wants the cars and and
that's who they go after really
and they they do promise those those
high returns and this is just
it just doesn't happen ryan thank you
for uh speaking out against this guy i
appreciate it
i know what you need this ain't what it
seems nothing but a trick
trying to sell me on a dream but that
was where you lost me